c'est bon on va poser latéral à raymond
à lennon question si tu ne vises
pourquoi dit on que ross stores bide
mon ami a la grosse tête pourquoi dit on
que fondation bid a la grosse tête
parce qu'il refuse de faire des sales
fille avec les gens dans la rue j'ai pas
anna rozen automatique regarder pourquoi
un pervers
mais pourquoi on dit que franck a la
grosse tête et l'échangé automatique
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est qu'en
ce moment franck gastambide a le vent en
poupe
le journal libération a offert à franck
gastambide un long portrait dans lequel
il revient sur sa carrière une carrière
qui n'était pas gagné d'avancé en raison
des difficultés d'apprentissage auquel
il a toujours été confronté je fais
encore trois fautes par mots j'ai
toujours du mal avec les langues
étrangères je n'ai jamais pu apprendre
les tables de multiplication je ne peux
pas réciter l'alphabet d'un seul coup si
ces difficultés ont toujours été pour
lui un complexe avec le succès de
nombreux psychologues l'ont contacté
pour lui expliquer qu'il était en fait
très probablement hpi comprenait un
surdoué
comme quoi malgré ses difficultés franck
gastambide prouve bien que le talent et
la passion mène à tout
et bam a dit exactement la même chose à
quoi vous de même chose alors voilà ça a
brisé ses rêves un voit la preuve que
j'embrasse un bien entendu est ce un
vrai gentil parce que manger comment cet
été un peu mois la vente sur tps au
début qu'il est venu en invité les
invités souvent ils oublient de parler
aux gens et moi une comédie ses livres
harry ne connaissent pas et il venait il
parlait c'est vraiment un vrai gentil
frangaz temps des cessions mais les gens
vous parlent non mais non mais vraiment
ça c'est pour les gens vous parlent et
ça ça fait du bien